but if you want to embarrass yourself in
front of your mates in another way you
can also go to an onsen as well a public
golf yes which i think is a much taller
hurdle for a lot of people i'd recommend
just going to uh you know you can book
like uh ryokans which normally have
onsens uh you can book them on like
booking.com yeah and even if you have
tattoos like uh you know you can if you
do yeah if you have the expandable in
the comments where would you recommend
for that though because before we we had
the massive onsen
uh in tokyo
unfortunately we can't recommend that
anymore because that was because i was
so sad i'm so sad because that was like
the perfect onsen to recommend because
you go to the onsen solution
and then you'd go you'd go to like diver
city and just see the massive gundam and
you're like
damn what a perfect day trip yeah that's
the perfect day trip unfortunately
that's not available anymore i still
think some of the well i mean it depends
how far out of tokyo you want to go into
i mean there's a lot of like small bath
houses in and around tokyo in like the
more uh like suburban areas uh but
that's not really an onsen if you want
like the onsen experience without going
too far out of tokyo i'd say hakone is
probably yeah
it's pretty good um that's in kanagawa
which is one prefecture across but you
can you can well not even you can get
the it's a romance car yeah yeah
yeah yeah i don't know
the romance car but it's basically like
it's like halfway between a bullet train
and a regular train it's like more
bougie than a regular train but it's not
as fast as a bullet train yeah and you
can go directly from uh shinjuku to
hakone in like an hour i think yeah
it's relatively cheap as well yeah
um and yeah it's a really really nice
little cute smile
yeah it's it's really cool it's got
there's this really small ava store um
right on the station yeah yeah yeah
which i go to every time i don't know
and the reason for that is because
hakone is uh what they based tokyo three
off of yeah um so if you've seen
evangelion and you've seen the movies uh
you all recognize the trains that like
that they use there because they look
exactly like they do and ava um you'll
be like oh
i see shinji right there listening to
listen to your headphones
disgusting
and you walk around you see vending
machines and like oscar and mari and
like gingees everywhere i really
recommend if you want like a nice kind
of maybe like a two-day trip outside of
uh tokyo because hakuna is not only
really good especially you know if you
love ava of course but like also you
know there's uh the jio kudani which is
like uh like the sulphur plumes of like
the mountains of hakuna is really nice
and there's like there before it's
really dope you go up this like huge uh
like i was about to say monorail it's
not a monorail it's like uh what do they
call it like this uh
[ __ ] what are they called it's like not
a ski lift but what's what
gondola yeah gondola that's it yeah you
got this like gondola from the base uh
of this lake uh in in uh in hakone and
you go up into the mountains and you get
this really really nice view of the lake
and on a good day like if the weather's
really good you can see this like
perfect view of mount fuji as well so
that's really dope and then you go into
this uh little valley and you go into
this place called
which is called hells valley um right
japan has a couple of hells valleys oh i
know yeah this is oh is there one
hokkaido there's one hokkaido as well um
and there's also one around like gifu as
well right um yeah it's just this like
really cool like sulphur plume
place where you can get really close to
like volcanic sulfur plumes kind of
smells like farts uh the entire time
yeah i mean but uh it's kind of a really
cool unique experience um yeah i
personally recommend it's a good day
trip yeah because i really khaka was the
first hot springs town that i went to
and i really enjoyed myself uh the one
thing i will say is if you go to hakone
um it's really
it's really weird because like i went to
hakone and i expected it to be something
it's not similar to tokyo but like you
expect to go to a hot spring and then
you expect to like walk around and
explore somewhere but like a lot of
ryokans they expect you to stay at that
one establishment for the entirety of
your trip right a lot of a lot of these
hotels and a lot of these ryokans will
have all um
will have all everything you need within
that facility because they don't really
expect you to go out and explore because
normally there isn't really much to
explore in that immediate area unless
you take a bus or something right yeah
um at least that was that's my
experience so yeah there's like don't
expect like you can go explore but if
you want to go explore you probably need
to plan it out a bit more because the
place you're staying in
is isn't necessarily going to be near
a lot of tourist attractions yeah um
especially if you're staying at a ryokan
um having said that if you do stay in a
ryokan uh be prepared to uh get up and
eat [ __ ] breakfast okay
that's that's that's that's one thing
which uh at an egregiously early time
i i i'm not sure if i am a fan of it but
if you do say ryokan ryogans are great
right we're kind of great because i feel
like in terms of hotels they're like the
most aesthetic place you can stay so
yeah you are pampered there it's great
it's the most authentic like japanese
accommodation experience yeah exactly
and then you normally have the nicest
onsens that you could you could find oh
you normally sleep on a on a futon
though on the floor so not a bed so if
that's something you might but if you
want that authentic japanese experience
futons i feel like are better than
bedsides yeah but people might not want
some people might have a thousand thread
count you know they might you know
you're thinking like where's my bed when
they get there oh is that it yeah but
like if you if you don't come down for
breakfast at the agreed time uh they
will find your family and they will kill
everyone you love or at least that's
what i get out of like if
it's like it's included in the cost as
well so yeah that's why they're normally
quite expensive because yeah dinner is
normally included yeah they don't want
you wasting money yeah yeah yeah i mean
you know these dinners are normally like
really large courses so they're like the
reason why already okay like you know
like ryokan's like normally like what
like three four hundred dollars a night
minimum
and that's because like half of that has
gone to the food if not food yeah you
will be eating like a king you will you
will eat like so if you see the price of
the ryokan um don't get too shocked at
the price because you're paying for the
food as well and it's normally like
really really really good food it's high
quality it might be even a bit too much
sometimes you'll get a good uh taste of
the local dishes though normally yeah
these local ingredients yeah and uh yeah
certainly a really good way to just try
japanese food that you normally wouldn't
order like i never i'm never gonna order
half the [ __ ] they give me oh yeah yeah
because half of it is super slimy yeah
uh but i always eat it because i don't
wanna you know have to make eye contact
with that small japanese lady who asked
me why i didn't like it which they have
done many times oh really yeah they yeah
so now i just i just i just eat
everything i i i ate everything but
originally when i didn't like eat
something they would sometimes just
stare at me like why didn't you eat it
what's wrong
[Laughter]
but no like it's like i i'd even like
recommend going to ryokan to try the
traditional japanese food over even
going to a restaurant right because with
the restaurant you don't know what to
order you know you don't you look at the
menu and it's like i don't know what i'm
going to like but it's kind of like
ryokan food is kind of like a tasting
menu you know you kind of get a little
bit of everything lots of little small
chunks of a lot of things
you're going to find something you like
some things you don't like but it's a
great way to just easily
get the traditional japanese experience
um just don't miss breakfast because uh
did they did
did i hear you say like they came to
your room once and woke you up to get
breakfast oh yeah
no yeah a woman literally i was i was
with chris
i think i was on a journey across japan
trip and one morning i got oh the night
prior i got very drunk uh so i want you
as we do as you do and then the morning
of
i was very hungover and uh you know and
the lady kept knocking on my door being
like breakfast ready and i'm like oh
yeah shut up shut up i have a throbbing
headache right now and then she [ __ ]
just walks in and just like rips the
sheet off me and i'm just like what are
you like what are you my mother like
yeah what the [ __ ] she was like making
sure you're alive and i was like you
[ __ ] all right
ripped it huh yeah well like oh like
slowly like took it off it's even worse
yeah that's like more creepy and i'm
like for one i'm freezing my ass off too
i have a throbbing headache three how
did you get in what the [ __ ] i've never
heard of them that's an exception though
that's that's something else most places
they'll just like ring you up on the
phone to make sure yeah
like five more minutes mom five more
minutes
please push like modern real cans if you
will that are more like they're like
they have beds like western yeah they're
like way more modernized um in hokkaido
called hotels well it's it's like it has
it's weird because it'll have tatami
mats oh but it'll have a bed and it'll
oh i
those are usually like more higher up
though right yeah but they normally it's
because i find that the prices aren't
different like really the really
traditional ones sometimes cost more
than the more modernized ones because
they're they charge a [ __ ] ton for food
or maybe they have
a lot of workers that's what they have
so many workers that really
insane they do but also sometimes the
service is nuts yeah they're like the
moment you turn up there's like four of
them greeting you they'll like take all
your bags right away and then oh my god
it's just like so intense i'm like jesus
christ yeah what's happening sometimes
it's a bit too intense right because
sometimes you're just like okay i i i
know you i know you're wanting to make
me feel comfortable but you're making me
feel a little bit too comfortable now
yeah like three or four recently with
chris on the video and it was really
i remember i walked up to one and uh
as we were driving into the euro clown
there was like 10 employees yeah
just like slowly bowed i was just like
bro i'm not the queen like literally you
feel it
you feel like royalty in the best way
yeah it's good there's a lot of
different price points and different
kind of uh
variations of enzymes and yeah and uh
one i think i've seen the one one
they're the snow monkeys oh yeah and
that was amazing because the whole town
is an onsen town um which town is this
it's called uh i think there's two i
think this one's called yutanaka
yeah yeah the other one was um
which is famous for like having a big
big onsen pit you can't go in it but
yeah there's a couple of them and uh
yeah honestly it's a nag whereabouts is
it not gonna so you could just
tokyo if you really want to you can
easily get the bullet train as well from
the bullet trains uh
yeah that's like the top three onsen
cities or towns that was so good because
we we stayed in london that was
literally like one foot away from the
town center
really cool really really cool yeah the
other top three i went to uh was
geronsen as well that's it
that one's really really that's the one
where chris and i uh bathed in a
thousand-year-old log
oh oh that one yeah that's that's a
thousand-year-old there's a bath made
out of thousand-year-old log and those
are actually really really nice that's
in ghetto when you guys book onsense
well i i know that's not a problem for
you joe but do you go with the english
sites or do you go with
fucking.com super easily okay uh unless
it isn't on booking.com which is quite
rare actually yeah i've never really
seen anything that's normal it's all on
booking.com okay which is really weird i
like you'd think like super traditional
but nah dude you you can book it all on
booking.com yeah have they modernized
have they actually miners i've i've
never seen a real can that i wanted to
go to that wasn't on booking.com right i
don't know why there is some hotels on
booking.com yeah yeah which is really
weird
um but yeah i i said a place one time
where like they didn't have the onsen
built in they had a hot tub so they
would fill the hot tub with onsen water
they brought in via truck
that's weird so is that really an onsen
it's an onsen if it has onsen water in
it okay yeah yeah okay
if you fill a bathtub with an onsen
water that's technically it's a nonsense
if i bring sea water in my bathtub is
this the sea it's the sea is it the sea
well yeah it's a [ __ ]
it's a c bathroom is it the sea though
is it a hospital there's no like there's
no place where you can go for the tm
onsen you know you know the word onsen
just means warm springs yeah yeah you
can just get it what makes it onsen is
that it has like the [ __ ] um minerals
yeah
and every single onsen has like the ph
sign and stuff that tells you what's
outside of it so they're really strict
on what can and can't be an onset
that's really strange yeah legally
speaking yeah yeah
but uh yeah i highly recommend just
getting over your fear of getting naked
in front of your mouth or whatever and
is that a
yeah for a lot of people jojo fans uh
that's don't this does not apply yeah it
doesn't apply to you yeah because i
remember like there's been a couple of
my friends uh who just like refused to
go to an onsen just because they were
like uncomfortable with getting naked in
front of me or you know the the mates
and i'm just like looks out for the boys
i'm like dicks out for the boys dude
like it's we all have them it's like who
cares you'll get over it in five minutes
you know it's a bonding experience it is
it is it is it is a morning experience
[ __ ] i love saunas dude yeah i like
[Music]
i like saunas i just can't stain them
for long i love it i love getting in the
ice cold water [ __ ] dude i don't like
that i don't like i don't you do the
things that i hate yeah
dude
the onsen for me is the warm-up for the
the sauna
oh really yeah i'm i'm i when it doesn't
have a sauna i get so sad but luckily in
japan now recently sauna's becoming like
a trend oh yeah some reason yeah people
are obsessed with saunas and the health
benefits yeah there's a lot of like
dedicated sauna places in japan yeah
yeah i'm and my god do i love a sauna
i love one dude it's very wide of you i
think that is very very white but like i
[ __ ] love it